c'est le mal c'est le mal absolu la
justice divine
s'appuie sur la prescription de faits de
crimes sexuels sur mineurs c'est ça
c'est ça votre religion vous êtes un
ouvrage de spiritualité
je suis rentré chez moi
diatement mes parents mais je les dis
plutôt sur le registre de la fierté
pensant à bénéficier de l'intérêt d'un
d'un homme très important à partir de là
mes parents m'ont retiré la troupe
scoute à partir de là ils ont été
fustigés par toute une communauté qui
accuse et mes parents de faire du mal à
l'église
la force de l'injonction qui a été posée
l'umih
que l'église a vécu c'est sûr que ça
donne énormément de
soulagement aux victimes c'est que la
honte elle a changé de camp moi je moi
je les ai regardés en face c'est eux qui
baissaient les yeux c'est qu'ils
baissaient les yeux
le pape n'a jamais
a
envoyé le moindre message essayé de
prendre contact avec nous et ce monsieur
nous dit nous laisse entendre qu'il est
il n'est pas informé qu'il n'était pas
conscient qu'ils découvrent la situation
mais non mais non bien sûr que non il ya
eu ces enquêtes à travers le monde que
le pape
n'a pas commenté autre que de dire ces
banalités d'exprimer sa honte mais c'est
de sa responsabilité et compte dont on
parle c'est pas de sa honte il est
parfaitement quand l'institution
puisqu'il a reçu lui-même barbarin et
qu' il a refusé sa démission et que et
il a il a fait valoir la présomption
d'innocence
je suis certain
or maléfique de ces crimes atroces et de
leur dissimulation et de leur
organisation en fait rien ne m'arrêtera
je n'ai rien à perdre je n'ai aucun
doute et je suis certain ce que je dois
faire